Che bella questa Escape Room Guarda che
bella quest'area ragazzi
Ah
ah ah ha concreto un'azione ti sei
laureato ah Grande c'è un nuovo cattivo
tra noi gol ma quello che vedete qua Mr
Beans è un uomo cattivo
almeno il Rainbow Friends
Non vedo l'ora di scoprire come sarà
questo nuovo cattivo cucciolo
sembra un giocattolo carino ma sappiamo
che anche dietro ai giocatori carini
possono nascondersi creature basta basta
quindi vediamo come sarà questo gioco
pronti gioca
dormendo io vedi
Eccomi seguito
cosa farò Allora le regole di classe del
signor wiggle c'era scritto Ci siamo
svegliati cosa sta succedendo stiamo
guardando intorno stiamo a scuola ecco
un disegno brutto
fiorellino
Ok Allora siamo qui ma Mister wiggles
non ci fa niente
tacos vomito e nucleare
Cosa
vomito e nucleare va bene
No io voglio provare assolutamente il
vomito Hahaha
[Musica]
non potete
mettere dentro le regole di classe del
signor Beagle 1 impara due divertiti 3
Non lasciare mai
non lasciare mai le cose nel piatto no
come me non c'è problema Io non la
lascio mai niente perché Grazie per
pensare al cibo Infatti anche oggi
Vitale ha il cibo in tempo
allora proviamo ad aprire questa porta
ma non si apre questa porta
in realtà c'è un passaggio segreto c'è
scritto mister wiggle non è come Mr
Smiley
Cattivo che si chiama questa Smiley se
questo video raggiunge i 3000 mi piace e
giocheremo anche a Mr smile così vediamo
com'è mi ricorda un po' è vero siamo
ancora a scuola Siamo tipo un piccolo
problema quel piatto in testa non riesco
a passare bene
il trucco dappertutto
Fammi passare prima allora qua c'è
scritto
Michael Che vuol dire Stai attento
Mister Wiko is very Smart Che vuol dire
Mr wiggle è molto intelligente Beh
sinceramente da quella faccia non sembra
proprio per niente Tanto se lo dite voi
No Secondo me bisogna che schifo Ma
perché non gli Escape Room dobbiamo
passare dalle foglie Ok abbiamo
sorpassato le fogne Vitale Parla per te
Io sono appena sfracellata no
oh ecco è radioattiva questa cosa verde
Comunque mi scioglie subito ogni istante
proprio Sono tornata a scuola è laggiù
c'è Mr Smiley Che carino sembra una
sorta di Smith
vado io avanti Vado via matti voglio
prenderlo prima volta che sei già andato
perché io ho preso da mangiare quindi
Cesena
Oh qui questo coso qui che si chiama
Mister Smiley School mascotte Ah è una
mascotte non ci farà niente della scuola
Sì questi sono le assi di legno Anita
dove sei carino Ciao Ciao mister smile
Io ho una mela e tu no l'hai fatto
prendere quella me la voglio pure io
perché tu vai velocemente vai
avanti Insomma si potesse Si potesse
attraversare di là invece no mi sono
solo spacellato adesso sto andando a
prendere la mela pure io magari trovo
qualcos'altro da mangiare
wow wow
C'è mister Wiko che mi guarda al
contrario ma è troppo carino È tenero
non fa paura per niente per ora eccola
mela l'ho preso anch'io la mela ah ah io
me la conservo casomai può servirmi io
me la mangio invece
di mangiarla affronteremo un mister
wiggle gigante
libretto nella lavagna ho mentito le
mele non mi fanno dormire Sei pronto per
andare alla scuola del signor Google
trova il bottone segreto per portarti lì
le mele non mi fanno dormire Comunque A
cosa servono
a quanto pare un'arma contro Mr Wiko ho
trovato qualcosa qui c'era scritto
qualcosa il pulsante segreto
Guarda è qualcosa di nascosto qua dietro
cosa dice Raccogli il pulsante veramente
pulsante si preme non si raccoglie Vabbè
hai premuto il pulsante Non lo so è
diventato verde era verde Guarda si è
creato una voragine qua Arcobaleno
sembra tipo uno scivolo gigante
3 2 1
non mi hai aspettato Ah ah ah
Wow siamo ci siamo rimpiccioliti pure la
scuola che è diventata gigante forse se
vuoi rimpiccioli di noi allora vediamo
questi sono dimenticati di tradurre in
italiano
credo che sia un esame ogni bambino
dovrebbe fare esercizi ogni giorno
quindi dobbiamo fare attività fisica per
crescere bene Oggi siamo tipo in
palestra No ma ci sono delle patate e
c'è anche una casa gigante qui Volevo
dire eh Oh guarda non è bellissima Ti
volevo far notare che qui a destra c'è
il cioccolato Lo vedi Guarda sono le
tavolette di cioccolato gigante io ti
tuffo lì adesso Oh il cioccolato è un
armadio
Eh sì credo che sia un armadio Come si
fa a nascondere a confondere il
cioccolato con l'armadio Guarda Tu dove
sei non riesco a vederti sono qua
davanti ti sta aspettando eh Ci sono i
tentacoli di Mr Bean Uh Quindi così Eh
sbrigati mamma non so se cadere dove
devo andare Non lo so aiuto Come faccio
a scendere da qui Aiutami Anita devi
saltare no sei andato dalla parte
sbagliata non dovevi saltare nel CD
dovevi saltare addosso di là dove ci
sono i pad per favore no
ho sbagliato Vabbè io vado allora Ciao
topolino il peggio devo prendere io
invece Uh
finora non mi hanno sfracellato i denti
come non detto
i tentacoli di questa guida e adesso
guarda chi è avanti chi è avanti adesso
sì voglio vederti Come si sfracelleranno
i tentacoli di Mr wikos
dobbiamo studiare bene come funzionano i
tentacoli di Mister wiggle Ok Sembra
troppo difficile
sono all'ultimo
Dai vieni Dai aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
allora aspetto qua che passi il
Tentacolo via
aspettiamo
via scappiamo
ce l'ho fatta
Escape Room ancora ce l'abbiamo fatta
Wow ci sono le forbici giganti
Attenzione Non farti sforbiciare e poi
le matite giganti È troppo bella questo
scherzo via via via via via via via
Dai fatti dagli uzzare dalle forbici
Uffa queste forbici vogliono dividere i
miei dolci che c'è sulla testa io non mi
limito da nessuno mi piace tutti
Wow
Sembra tipo un piccolo villaggio
scolastico che carino
vediamo cosa c'è scritto nella lavagna
si ricevi ora giochiamo un gioco Trova
tre forme e mettile sulla Controlla
molto bene
allora troviamo tre forme da mettere
sulla tracolla
controllata Allora
sì ho trovato il quadrato anche tu avevi
trovato il quadrato
Vediamo se trovo qualcosa qua sopra
Vediamo eh allora Forza Napoli
Ho capito ho capito Ci sono degli indizi
disseminati da qualche parte davvero no
Penso di sì Non lo so io l'ho
interpretato così lui non lo so
cioè così pare non mi dove
Mi manca solo il triangolo
contro il segno con ferito che cosa Boh
non lo so Ho preso un mezzo Se mi dici
dov'è il triangolo e io ti dico come
fare a prendere il Belgio
poverina Come hai fatto a trovarlo e io
sono solo Castello quindi di Disney
Oh Che figo Uffa può trovare dov'era il
posto perfetto
[Musica]
si è aperta la porta
più dove era il triangolo
ciao ciao ciao Ecco Mister Wiko
e l'ora della classe hai 5 domande
rispondi con una parola o un numero
ottieni tre possibilità
cos'è 3x4 cos'è 3 + 4 7 te lo dico cos'è
10-8 2
dove vanno i bambini per imparare dal
dentista scuola al parco giochi
sono piuttosto semplici come domande
forse ma sono troppo facili
In cosa si trasformano i bambini quando
crescono
in Dio un tacos in adulti Sarebbe bello
se fosse tanto
io sarei molto contento
Congratulazioni ti sei laureato Ah
grande basta così poco laurearsi
non sei più un bambino no questo non mi
piace
buttiamoci Giù da questo tunnel quindi
anche tu stai facendo il quiz per
laurearsi
Congratulazioni ti sei laureato non sei
più un bambino e vai e adesso Ciao che
bella questa Escape Room Guarda che
bella quest'aria Adesso abbiamo finito
possiamo tornare indietro
fantascientifica No tu credi di aver
finito l'escape Room ma ancora se sono
altre aree Questo è bellissimo
Ah si può scendere quaggiù Sì come prima
Uh Uh Uh che figo Allora ci sono due
freccero tutto Attenzione attenzione
pazzesco ma dove siamo è stranissimo ho
preso un documento volante ci sono tanti
documenti volanti
stanno lanciando le lauree
[Musica]
vado prima io boh
a prendere il badge Dove dove vai vai
vai
supermercato
No non ci credo che tu stai prendendo
bene l'immagine
[Risate]
mi sta facendo troppo divertire
Quest'anno come parlare dopo i pasti
laureata
c'è scritto sconfiggi mister wiggles per
scappare
Ma dov'è C'è mancato poco
Oh no cosa è successo Anita dobbiamo
affrontare Mister wiggles Meno male
avevo confermato la mela Io ce l'ho però
È gigantesco
che paura è enorme
cosa devo fare Aspetta ma come faccio a
sconfiggerlo spiegatemi qualcosa
Cioè lui vuole schiacciare con i
tentacoli ma io non so cosa devo fare
datemi un'arma qualcosa dobbiamo usare
la mela Anita Io vorrei aiutarti
non funziona prigioniero qui Mister
wiggle Al momento
no
Vediamo se ora compare il fucile ma
forse ti è disarmato
non credo Non lo so e io ce l'ho però
capito
Devo per forza comprare verità cosa ho
il vomito e il nucleare
Allora Comprerò il vomito Oh no mi
mancava pochissimo
Vediamo adesso
[Musica]
Speriamo che funzioni qualcosa con i
tacos Io ce l'ho fatta l'ho colpito ok
Ho preso il tacco che stai sparando uh
ah ah ah
ah ma non funziona proprio niente
ma uffa che tu c'hai il tacos in mano
sei felice vero
credo che si sia buggato il gioco e
quindi non mi va apparire l'arma non
posso sconfiggere ogni tanto Ok
Purtroppo il mio gioco si è buggato non
mi fa aprire apparire il fucile per
sconfiggere mi segui quindi continuiamo
dal gioco digitale
tutta la vita Tu tu tu tu tu tu Google
sarà di là guarda sta scappando col 10%.
dov'è andato Mr Beagle che ti stai
prendendo qualcuno qui ma questo gioco È
super buggato Sì
non mi scapperai adesso ti prendo tu tu
dove sei limoni Non lo so dov'è Mr Wiko
non mi dire che il peggio
interagisci No tu stai cadendo con
l'ascensore a forma di pietra adesso
forse Oh dove siamo finiti qui che bello
un'altra parte della scuola è bellissima
dice alla prossima signor wiggle quindi
è ancora vivo perché altrimenti non ti
avrebbe detto alla prossima è vero due
era l'uno Dov'è il badge Ehi
Google vai Segui la freccia Ah eccolo
vedi di qua dovevo andare poi da qui si
sale sopra
un assaggio segretissimo
Cosa erano quei rumori
a scuola
e adesso laggiù mi sembra che ci sia la
prima
parte Ehi che cosa dice Mister Smiley
the
Cureggio
dove siamo andati
salta al volo felice Santa velocità
del gigante che balla Vai vai vai
Mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace E
ora vi lasciamo
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
eh Buona visione Ciao